been giving you hints throughout the
show and it's finally time to find out
who our mystery guest is all right first
let's review the clues number one
just received a star on the hollywood
walk of fame
number two wine as in cabernet
not wine as in complain and finally
number three
related to jungle book author rudyard
kipling
who the heck could it be mystery guests
reveal yourself
it's kathy lee gifford
kathy lee it's so great to see you i do
not think i've seen you
since i was on the today show when we
were in makeup i don't even know how
long ago was that was i don't know 10
years ago
i don't know you look the same diapers
then laura and guess what
i'm in diapers again it's just been too
long
oh my goodness well it's so great to see
you and
i want to get i want to get to one of
the funniest things
um i learned about you that you were the
singer
on name that tune the old game show
um which i loved so how many songs did
you have to learn for that
200 songs in five days but when you're
young and hungry you can do anything yep
200 songs in five days and i did the
entire season in just a couple of weeks
never made one mistake i mean it was i
could never do that again
it was it was intense so you could name
that tune
in four notes three notes seven notes
i was the la la lady and so i i was the
one that
would give the clue so so i would go all
right nate uh here's the song
and i they'd give me a time meter and
and uh two bars of something and i'd go
in with the orchestra and i go la la
but only worth living but not always
living it's your la la
and people would go born free
oh my free that movie all right all
right now your longtime friend um passed
away last july uh regis philbin of
course
co-host uh of yours for 15 years said
that
those years he spent with you were his
best years
in television tell us about the first
time you met him
we did not have an auspicious first
meeting i was a west
west side um of new york and there was
nobody around i don't know why i was
walking uptown he was walking downtown
and we weren't even thinking about so we
both got
sort of close to each other at the same
time we went up oh
oh hi and then we just kept walking but
i was always a huge fan of regis because
every time i'd watch him
he was doing something stupid but it was
hysterical
or he was doing something brave which
nobody had ever done before but he
always seemed fearless to me
and he always seemed to really love his
audience
nothing was ever done in a way to be
offensive interestingly enough and don
ripples was one of his closest friends
and don rickles is the exact opposite
just ripping everybody to pieces but one
of the sweetest
world in real life regis was every man
he just was and he had the greatest
attitude of gratitude he just couldn't
believe
that out of all the people on this
planet he got to be regis
and in a way i i saw him two weeks
before he died lord and it broke my
heart because
i hadn't seen him he and joy had moved
to california uh
for the most part and of course it was
coveted at that time and
and i had seen him in months since i was
in la
and i saw him get out of the car and
walk towards my house and i went oh
lord this is going to be the last time
i'm going to see my friend i just knew
it
but we picked up right where we did
before and we
laughed and the nice thing about the
great thing about it that i always
cherish is that
regis and i became great friends when we
worked together for 15 years
but after i left the show for the next
20 years we became even
much deeper crazy all right kathie lee
it's time for a little thing we do it's
called this or that it's right up your
alley
it's pretty simple i'm going to just
name two things and you have to just
pick whichever you like better okay
we're going to put 30 seconds up on the
clock
and try to get through as many of these
as we can we start
now cabernet or chardonnay
rose all day or jose no way
rose half today filming tv
or filming movies filming movies writing
books
or songs songs now you've already given
this up connecticut or tennessee
i still have both thank god better
co-star
sharks from sharknado 3 or hoda
oh but she also did sharknado 3 with me
and finally emmy award or star on the
hollywood walk of fame
oh emmy or hollywood walk of fame that's
easy i think well
for emmys thank you lord but i've been
and and frank when he found out i was
being nominated for that he said
don't you aren't you on that already i
don't know what i want anymore i know
what happened to that
what happened to that delay okay that's
a little that's like how many wait how
long ago was that you should have been
on that
10 year 15 years ago not that i deserve
it it's just that that's that's the kind
that's the world i live in you know if
you've been around you've survived
enough critics
and you haven't uh you know been um
scandalized so
so badly that people you know cult they
cancel you
you know i'm still here and they don't
know what to do with me well kathy lee
kathie lee i'm coming to nashville and
i'm hanging out with you
and we're definitely having wine
definitely
the whole world's moving here you'll
love the taxes
all right kathie lee great to see you
thank you so much
god bless thanks for having me all right
there's a lot more of my conversation
with kathie lee
and go to foxnation.com right now after
the show and watch the full
interview hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else